Negotiations between Hollywood studios
and the Writers Guild are expected
to resume next week,
according to multiple reports.
The strike is now almost four months
old and talks broke off in mid-August.
And it comes as both Drew
Barrymore and Bill Maher
announced this week
that their talk shows
would resume production without writers.
They join several other talk
shows that have been airing new episodes,
including The View and Live
with Kelly and Mark.
The writers went on strike
back in May,
demanding better pay
and a change
to the compensation structure
as the industry moves toward
a streaming model and away
from traditional broadcasting.
The Actors Guild went on strike
two months later over
many of the same issues,
but they also won an agreement
that protects actors
against some of the uses
of artificial intelligence
in film and television.
I want to bring in Michael Jackman.
He is a television
comedy writer and showrunner
who has worked on shows
such as King of the Hill,
Rules of Engagement, and Tacoma, FDR,
among others.
Good to see you.
Michael.
So are you any more optimistic today
than, I don't know,
a couple of months ago
when all of this got underway
that perhaps
negotiations can get underway
and there could be
some sort of deal struck?
As a professional sitcom writer.
I'm trying
not to be optimistic about anything.
We get our hopes up all the time.
I really hope
that we can get a much better
offer from the studios
because we all want to get to work,
all of it.
You know, I'm in my garage
and I mentioned I'm in my garage now.
I could be sitting on a yoga mall
if I had to be so long.
I want to be back at work.
Yeah.
And can you kind of paint a picture?
What are a lot of writers doing right now
to make ends meet, to pay the bills,
you know, well,
while they are on the picket line,
or at least supporting what's happening
Yeah.
I mean, that
that's the thing
like when I first broke into the business
you could make this is
I don't want to say what 1990.
You can make a living full time
as a comedy writer on a show.
You know,
if you're working,
let's say ten months out of the year,
you take a hiatus and go back to work
and it was.
But now if you're on a hit show
a really a hit show
you might only work
eight or do eight
or ten episodes in a season.
And so then how do you get
how do you get by.
Sometimes your contract won't like it
sometimes you can scramble
and pick up some side
works out, sell a pilot or
there's a lot of hustle.
Back in 2008 when the last strike was,
I remember
the leverage from the studio was,
what can you guys really afford
to be out of work for three months?
And we're like, No, not really.
But now they've lost that leverage.
Can you guys afford to be out of work
for once?
We're already out of work
nine months out of the year.
You lost that leverage
when you turned our Japanese department
professional. So.
So, you know, I teach courses, stuff
where I have a book coming at
whatever you can do to hustle.
Yeah,
but it's been hard for a lot of people
because some people are having
to sell their assets because,
you know,
they they cannot
they can no longer
make ends meet in a while.
And while this is happening,
I do want to play a clip that you posted
back in July, if we could.
Let's do that. Yeah.
Today
I am picketing the surface of the sun.
I don't know what to send it
to the writers, but apparently something
you know, I don't ask questions.
So I just show up, you know,
4000 degrees.
I tell you what,
back when it was just the writers
and the picket line,
the place stunk of sunscreen.
But now that the actors have joined
us, right now,
it stinks of cocoa
butter and lemon juice cleanse.
So a little tongue in cheek there.
But, you know,
so when you were doing that in
July, did you.
Were you a little bit
more hopeful
that perhaps everyone will be
would have been back to work by now
with an agreement in place
and you know,
that it would be
a totally different scenario
than what it is now.
You all right? You know what?
When the actress joined us in the strike,
it definitely helped it
because their high profile
you know,
they're higher profile than writers.
So it definitely added a little weight,
a little more power to the cause.
So was I hopeful?
Yeah, a little.
Yeah. Yeah.
And then, you know, as we mentioned,
you know,
some shows are getting back on the air
next week.
The view has been on.
They make mention of the fact
that they have been doing
so without their writers,
their handwriting,
you know, their own material.
Drew Barrymore,
her show is returning to production,
but she's been taking a lot of heat
for, you know, getting back to business,
even though she says it's
going to be in compliance with the strike
and that they won't have writers.
Maybe you can explain to us,
you know what,
why she is getting so much heat.
Why are circumstances different for her?
Are they?
I don't know. I don't know if they are.
I think I think everyone's taking heat
I think maybe in Drew's case,
she's such a beloved personality.
Like she's she's charming,
she's endearing.
She seems very empathetic.
And so it's not like I don't think,
oh, I'm not angry
and I'm just kind of disappointed
because it actually hurts.
The more weight,
the more pressure
you can put on the studios
to make a deal,
the faster this comes to resolution
by putting your show back on,
you take that pressure off.
And so is
it just disappointing in the sense that,
you know, we all love her, you know, that
when your kids do something wrong,
you're just disappointed.
But when my neighbors something wrong,
same thing. I'm not disappointed.
I don't really care because I don't
you know, I don't love that.
Are you disappointed?
In the other shows, too?
Because, you know,
I guess everyone from set design,
you know, to catering,
there are a lot of jobs involved
in getting all those shows on the air.
And, you know,
perhaps a lot of those shows are saying
we want as many people as possible
to get back to work,
even though we know
many of the writers cannot.
So is that something
that's taken into consideration
or is it an issue of,
like you just said,
to make the strike strong,
everyone has to be on one accord
in terms of, you know,
the Actors and Writers Guild
a part of what's at stake is
so if shows in the future,
and I think this is what their goal is in
the near
future, is have shows written
and performed inside the computer
and when that's the case,
there is no need for a hair,
makeup, wardrobe set, camera operators.
All those jobs go away
when the show is made
inside the computer.
So this is a fight.
This is everyone's fight. It's coming.
And so I think we should first
take the stand on it.
All right.
Michael Jackman.
Glad you could be with us.
Thanks so much.
Perhaps we'll keep tabs with you because.
Sure, everybody,
you know,
wants some resolution, but
you're you're helping
helping us to kind of
get a sense
as to what
everybody is going through
on a day to day basis.
Hopefully we'll have you back.
Thank you so much. I'd love to.